[music playing]
NARRATOR: Dr. Colleen
Darnell hunts for clues
to solve the mystery of
why dozens of pharaohs
were removed from
their original tombs,
and reburied in
an unmarked grave.
[music playing]
Could this ancient
papyrus hold the answer?
COLLEEN DARNELL: One of the
more remarkable documents
to survive from ancient Egypt is
a transcript of the confessions
of a tomb robber.
NARRATOR: The papyrus was
long ago torn down the middle.
The two halves now live
in different museums.
But by bringing the
pieces together,
Colleen can decode the ancient
confessions of a New Kingdom
tomb robber named
Amenpanufer, who
broke into the tomb of a pharaoh
named Sobekemsaf the second.
COLLEEN DARNELL: We
took our copper tools
and we broke into its
very inner chamber,
and we know that they're going
through the mummies themselves
because they talk about
a piece of gold jewelry
at the neck of the king.
NARRATOR: Amenpanufer
admits to digging a tunnel
into the tomb of the pharaoh.
Once inside, he took as
much gold as he could carry,
but he was caught.
For his crimes, a
brutal punishment.
Sentenced to death by impaling.
This tomb robbery,
and others like it,
alarms New Kingdom authorities.
Their pharaoh's
mummies, so sacred
to the ancient
Egyptians, aren't safe.
The authorities take action.
COLLEEN DARNELL: In order to
safeguard the royal mummies,
they were moved,
rewrapped, and buried
together in an unmarked tomb.
We know that the plan worked.
By moving them from
the Valley of the Kings
to an unmarked
tomb, they survived
for thousands of years.
[music playing]